[Music] The
world means that all peoples preserve their heritage and their
history. We are destroying history and heritage.
Someone talks to you and tells you what. I mean, it is a mosque. My
brother. The mosque is a woman. It is 300 years old. It is more than 300
years old. It is beautiful. I am the exact area. The
fall of the lighthouse. This is what caused
all parties to fall into conflict.  This problem was the first,
and I say, I do not know. I mean, Mr. Governor, when he
demolished the minaret in this way. Is it an ill-considered decision? Is it a rush in the decision? Is it a lack of
study?
[Music]
Can we wait? I would say a year and a half to
demolish this mosque and rebuild it with a mosque worthy of the gentlemen of the
faithful and praying people of the people.  Basra I
may say it again that Abu Al-Athar delayed us
to dismantle the lighthouse
[music]